Black Panther is coming to theaters but
should you claw your way to get tickets
I brought the cornet and that's what
happens to the puns when Dan's not here
Daniel Radford hello right here we
should say that mr. John Murrell was not
able to see the movie yet yeah we were
able to see the movie so we have this
review and then we will also have a
spoiler filled review once the movie
opens featuring Dan and his thoughts
let's get right into this overall
thoughts Daniel overall very much
enjoyed it really really liked the movie
just kind of generally the costuming the
world-building those were some of the
things I think were the best and
strongest I think the character
development was the most I want to say
that I've seen a Marvel movie and those
are kind of my overall thoughts but
overall really really enjoyed the movie
yeah so did I I want to dig in piece by
piece because I think that pretty well
encapsulate the experience let's start
with this first of all the minute that
we started to hear about this movie
coming together right it was one thing
after the other of saying wow this thing
is going to be excellent because it's
just stacked first you get ryan coogler
to direct your movie which we have to
say this he directed the hell out of
this movie when Creed came out I
remember thinking like wow this movie is
one of the most well directed movies of
the year this is so much better than it
has any right to be he takes the
material and elevates it and he took
really really strong material here and
elevated it once again I agree and
especially I I cannot imagine how hard
it must be to go from making more
personal stories even Creed itself like
with all of its it's obviously splashy
it's obviously right at the rockiness of
it all to take what are more personal
stories and then your next big project
is like Oh a huge Marvel movie and yeah
yeah no pressure at all and especially
this Marvel movie because we're dealing
with a world
we have not really been to and that we
have not explored and to be able to go
in and make us I'm you know not to not
to not to romantic comedy I'd like oh
you know New York is like the fifth
character but no like what kind of is a
character in this movie and that is an
extra challenge to a Marvel movie
because it's not just like a team of
dudes running at a team of dudes for two
hours yeah you do have to build this
world absolutely he has to bring it to
life in such a way that it satisfies
comic-book fans who've been wanting to
seem Wakanda come to life and then also
the average moviegoer maybe has no idea
but it's still we are still equally
drawn into this world which is this
fascinating high-tech insulated reality
that is so unique and it's beautifully
rendered gorgeously shot we have to call
out cinematographer absolutely Rachel
Morrison because my god oh my it's
absolutely and the thing that I
appreciated the most was that you never
you never forget that you're in Africa
and you also never forget that you are
dealing with a city that is a
technological marvel like you've never
everything I liked it like you've never
forget that in in the way that the
technology and the fashion and the
culture have been so well integrated
into each other is that you know the
beautiful colors yes the wonders of
being able to show off the technology
and all the great work that the post
team obviously did to make that come to
life
it's really it is nothing like you've
seen before for a movie that isn't
explicitly like oh we're in space and
that's why it's a jungle and it's you
know and also you get all these
technological wonders it's a step above
and beyond our world and it should feel
that way but still accessible to some
how great and that's and what I really
liked about how he brought Wakanda to
life other than visually addition to
visually
is that it was shown to us via the
character so he married those things
together so when we get to know Cherie
that's how we get to know how technology
works in this world so he's affording
her her moments we get to really know
that character and we get to know a
piece of Wakanda through her we get to
know another piece of Wakanda through to
Chawla himself we get to know another
piece through Forest Whitaker Zuri
because they were so seamlessly married
together one wasn't in sacrifice of the
other right and it doesn't feel and
again non-spoiler review but I was
expecting that most of the heavy lifting
on kind of the audience insertion
character was gonna be on every K Ross
hmm and it wasn't it was equally spread
out so it never felt like oh look at all
of these wonders and I'm like this weird
guy here who suddenly dropped in the
middle of it sometimes unfortunately one
character has the job of being
exposition man yes you know like a Giles
on Buffy or sure doctor exposition a
doctor exposition and it never felt that
way it still felt like even as things
were being explained and we were being
exposed to new concepts about this world
and particularly this country in this
Marvel Universe it's still very much
felt natural yes and not like exposition
exposition exposition exposition that's
perhaps the most impressive thing about
this is that everything is motivated by
story and character and as a result
we're getting to know the world because
of the circumstances he's showing not
telling right we get to know a little
bit about how the rituals work because
that's a part of the story and we're
seeing it happen right there in real
time and showing that telling is
obviously it's one of the tenants of
theater it's one of the tenants of
movies but you know you can go back to
an example of one it doesn't work very
well and for me you know that white room
matrix scene is where there's way too
much showing and not enough talent or
way too much sorry telling and enough
showing and you can flip it on its head
in the first matrix when they're talking
and there's still like exposition man
but they're showing you through the
construct of what they've built they're
showing you what's happened to the world
and
this I feel like because all of these
things were so married to these
different characters again it's not like
sure you know Sheree is showing me the
technology it's like no she's like this
is what she does and this is what she
loves and so not only did I get to learn
more about how the technology in Wakanda
works it also served to show me more
about Sheree and how she was important
and how she fit in that's a huge feat
yeah it is and I each one of these
performances we were talking about this
earlier you know this is a cast filled
with great actors and every single one
of them is 100% present no one is
funding and in every one is completely
committed to their character and to this
world
I mean Danai gurira if you weren't in
love with her before from Walking Dead
you're in love with her now I'll tell
you that right now
yes but this goes across the board
chadwick boseman certainly Michael B
Jordan everybody's been talking about
that performance we'll get more into it
in a little bit but again what he did
here is similarly what Ryan Coogler did
is similarly to Creed is honored what
the world was but also bring it more to
us
yeah and it's through the performances
because they are so grounded no I
absolutely agree um and everyone and
this was something else that we we
talked about after the screening
everyone got their moment mm-hmm every
one of the actors like when you look at
all of the you know the hashtag Black
Panthers so lit and you see the grid of
actors and everyone being so excited
trust me when I tell you that whoever
you walked in being excited to see they
will get their moment and it's fantastic
yeah and overall they work sort of
together so that we understand the
nature of the relationships the other
big thing about this movie that's so
extraordinary is that here's what's cool
it both feels contained right it's
really focused on this world and Wakanda
what's happening with these characters
we're not really worried about what
other people may or may not be doing
that are part of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but it opens up that universe
to tap into and address
very very real very very relevant issues
in our world it does not back away from
that it has something bold to say when
we came out of the movie we said this
was the only thing they could have done
but I also can't believe they did it
yeah can't believe and it's fantastic
and it's it's it's marvel and one of the
things I've been most excited about
since I've seen the movie and it's
something I've talked about on shows
previously the idea that within these
genre movies you can also it's a way to
open up conversation it's a way to talk
about other things and and it's also a
way to have other genres like this is
also very much and people have said this
so I don't feel like this is a huge
spoiler it's also a political thriller
it's about the politics of Wakanda and
the idea that you were able to have a
movie that can be both things all things
plus still very much feel like it
belongs in the Marvel Universe is
fantastic yeah I mean that that sort of
blows my mind and that's one of the
things that I think we're all really
looking forward to diving into because
it has to do with and this is what we'll
talk about next the villains and the
portrayal of the villains absolutely big
topic of conversation for everybody is
Marvel has a villain problem with the
exception of one or two maybe Loki you
know and stay on the Netflix series
there are two villains here in my mind
one is Klaw yes who is Andy Serkis and
he's great he's fantastic
right like he's like big and frothy and
he gives this great performance he's
having so much fun he is having the time
of his life on this set as claw and it's
fantastic and you can tell but you can
feel when someone is like oh I know what
movie I'm in and I'm going to give this
everything that I have I know a
character I'm portraying the Andy Serkis
is a gem and we never deserved him yeah
we never did no but we got him and
that's the great thing because as you're
watching his performance you're
delighted with him and it's a big and
it's frothy and it's fun to watch and so
you get this one villain that's like
that kind of great villain to watch and
then you get Michael B Jordan who is
arguably the most interesting character
in the film he will break your heart
his storyline is one of the most
captivating in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe to date absolutely and it's not
to be obviously too spoilery I said
earlier that this felt like a
character-driven Marvel film and by that
I definitely mean it's not this isn't
gonna be the film where it's like you
know we have to rush to this thing to
that thing oh no there's a Doomsday
Clock oh no there's a bla bla bla bla
bla this is about the relationships
between the characters the history
between the characters and you can chart
where this villain decided to go upon
the path that he goes on and while
you're watching it even if you don't
agree with him you can at least say that
makes sense I could see how this could
happen
oh yeah I think you have nothing but
empathy even though what he's doing is
not something that you know as an
ethical being you can write you can be
his name is kill monger but at the same
time you absolutely get why he'd get
there he got there and you want more of
him you want to get to know him more you
are fascinated by his relationship
absolutely he is I I walked away from
age of Ultron with having some empathy
for Ultron I genuinely did a lot of
people didn't I saw where they were
going and I had some empathy but there
were still kind of something it didn't
quite get me where it needed to be and
even though I definitely disagree with a
lot of what kill mongers plan and what
he wanted to do at the end of it you
cannot help but have empathy for him and
that is amazing it's amazing that it's
not just you know and I don't feel like
this is super spoiler in it you know
he's not a mental monster that's come to
you know laser off people's eyeballs or
whatever he is a real person with real
motivations and with and this story has
a better and sighting incident that I
want to say most Marvel movies have I
think it has a better and more dynamic
and richer inciting in
than any Marvel movie has because yep
this is an inciting incident that will
have all of us talking and thinking and
feeling in a real way and you do in the
movie you want to cry for him and and in
the way that that Magneto and Professor
X absolutely um need each other T'Challa
and Eric need each other as well in this
absolutely order to fill their own arcs
mm-hmm and everyone there are these
dynamic character arcs and so this is
really about watching almost all of the
characters in this watching their
philosophies change yes and watching
their worldview change beyond any kind
of superficially I'm good you're bad and
I've realized how good it is to be good
everyone can agree about so the thing
that's motivating him um Eric is a thing
that eventually everyone can agree is a
problem right and how you address that
problem is where they disagree and there
is nothing more real than that it is so
caring nothing more compelling than that
and there is nothing more real than that
that we face every day as human beings
together and that brings up the question
is Black Panther the most interesting
character in the Black Panther movie or
is it Eric Gill monger I mean they're
all fantastic no I have always I mean I
don't know as a longtime reader of the
comics is a longtime reader of comics in
general is a long time you know same as
you a longtime person who watches movies
and love genre film and loves this the
villain is always worried missed even
when it's done right the villain should
be more interesting it is more
interesting to be like how does someone
get to a point where they think that
that's okay that's way more interesting
to me then you know I do what's right
because of what's right which is also
i'ma say like I don't want to distill
Chadwick Boseman performance down to
that at all because he goes through a
fan
character mark and that's the the
villain should provoke thoughts in the
hero of what am i doing how can I do
this better how can I be a better person
they still manage to like infect that
infect with it to affect change yes and
that's and that's that's one of the
things that made you know x-men movie so
compelling is this idea of it's like
this philosophy for versus this
philosophy we all want mutants to be
treated fairly but how far do we go and
how do we get there yes and that is
always and that I mean that is the
struggle like I'm you know I love Alex
Ross but when he's like oh I don't like
it he's a painter guy but he's like I
you know I love x-men but I think that
they're just it's just gang warfare it's
I get to know it's it's a war between
two different philosophies exactly and
that's what black panther is I agree it
is a hundred and that's what makes it so
fascinating and I would argue that that
yes yes come on car has sort of like a
more interesting in the sense that it's
more outside of us because we he wants
to go to places and do things that
normal human beings thank God but where
I would argue that that Chadwick Boseman
is beautiful in the portrayals gorgeous
is that he is us yes to me in a much
heightened way like he if we're not all
kings and we don't have that wait but
the questions that he's asking himself
is how much do I leave my kingdom and we
all have our own little kingdoms the
worlds that we live in and the care that
I give to the people that are directly
in my life and recognize that I am in a
part of a much larger world that I can't
solve in one fell swoop and yet I must
engage yes and that's that is a pretty
fascinating journey and we know that
from the trailers that it's about what
kinda coming into the larger world and
as an individual he has to take that
journey and I actually think it's a
pretty great one right and that was
something that we talked about that we
had spoken about earlier this idea that
like you know yes we know that like
sometimes something like a fast-fashion
can be bad because of conditions and we
know that like
something like necessarily like our
phones aren't aren't always made with
you know the care and they're not always
made in like the kindest ways and so we
all live in these kind of dual worlds if
it's our own world where we obviously we
obviously have to take care of ourselves
or taking care of our families and then
we also have to find how we can best be
as kind and serve the rest of the world
in a way that we can while still
honoring our connections to who we are
and who we love and what's just possible
and feasible and maintaining our
personal responsibilities in our own
lives and that is the balance and so I
would say that it I don't think it's
fair really to either the character of
Black Panther or to Chadwick to say that
that's not interesting because it's just
a bit more so it's just far more yellow
oh and it's not it's not boring yeah
it's just you know it'll be Michael B
Jordan as the Michael B Jordan of it all
and that is like his character is
obviously like you said so different
than us yeah that you want to understand
how someone gets there but I definitely
don't want to say that like Black
Panther is incredibly interesting and he
fights so much he you know he has this
fight between tradition and modernity
yeah that is incredibly fascinating yeah
and it's tradition and modernity in the
midst of being like 10 million times
more technologically you've never seen
where it's like no it's they're they're
so far ahead of the rest of us and yet
they still have to deal with how they
want to deal with the modern world
compared to still having their own
traditions it's it's pretty fascinating
because it's also how much can how much
can the modern world handle what we've
got you know can they even handle the
level of technology that we've got so
there's multiple issues happening all at
once let's talk about I would say that
if I had complaints about the film which
I really think again keep in mind this
is a Marvel movie this is a superhero
movie and all that that implies in that
container it's doing really special
things and it is a very extraordinary
and well-executed movie but it runs into
some of the Marvel third-act issues I
guess the little runs into the same
issues that many of
these movies do when they got back to
the characters is when I clicked right
back in I will say this qu and it can't
be understated this is a movie that is
pretty special in the sense that it is a
very historically relevant film that
also invites us all to enjoy a big epic
superhero movie that happens to be
really good you know like final thoughts
on this is like not only is this just a
good movie right but I hope that this is
a movie that because it is so good and
in hand-in-hand with it being as good as
it is that really we do start to see
more of the sea change that I think we
all want and desire I think that that
was what a lot of us you know after
obviously dark night now amazing dark
night was a lot of us was like okay this
is the standard this is what its gonna
be and in some ways it isn't sometimes
and some superhero movies are just like
we're gonna be fun it's gonna be all of
your favorite characters do interacting
and great and it's like with Marvel
that's really fun and that's fantastic
but I have seen that movie so while I am
excited to see more of that movie I am
happy that now I get to see this other
kind of movie as well because if I did
have to and I'm not there not a
one-on-one comparison but in terms of
the way that it handled like
philosophical questions and the way that
the villain was able to make the hero
think about themselves and then in the
way that they have done things that is
what I would compare it to as far as
like those two things and so I am hoping
that now we do get more still give me
fun stuff totally gonna see it totally
gonna have a good time be silly be fun
be like ant-man where you turn a
building into a backpack I'm totally
into it
but I enjoy that we are opening this
genre up to have more movies that are
about something that's a little bit
deeper than just isn't it fun to see all
of your favorite guys on screen at the
same time yes I think that the cool
thing about superhero films is that now
they're a proper genre with rates tons
so you can do all kinds of thing I'll
kind of subgenres
I've always wanted yeah that's what I've
wanted to and I feel like we really got
it here it's interesting to see where
Marvel's gonna go next
Danielle any final thoughts yeah I loved
this movie it made me incredibly happy
the women in this movie are amazing and
there are many scenes where they steal
the scenes so be prepared for that and
obviously it hits me in like a way
because representation is important it
is important to see yourself represented
on screen and seeing so many wonderful
powerful amazing characters that are
well written it's not just like because
how much would it have sucked if this
movie sucked so much would that have
sucked yeah we're so like it was so
upsetting
if this sucked and so the fact that they
were able to not only be able to do a
movie that is like this huge black a.f
movie for Marvel which is amazing but
the fact that it was good I worried
because I was like oh god if this is bad
I want this to be you know I want it to
live up to a standard and it more than
exceeded my expectations and I think
that if this and thor ragnarok are the
ideas about where the Marvel Universe is
heading into the next phase of being
able to say like you know what for
Ragnarok I can do this and make this
look like nothing else has done and you
guys are gonna love it I'm gonna make
this a huge comedy and I'm gonna do this
and I'm gonna change it and it's gonna
be great and the idea that we're now
what both of these movies had in common
were that they had teams and directors
and writers who it felt like were really
able to put their mark on this movie and
it didn't feel like that kind of movie
by committee that I think has been some
of the some of the complaints mm-hmm
about the Marvel Universe and so I am
very excited to see more directors come
in and put their stamp on these yeah me
too
I will
say this I agree it would have sucked
but I didn't worry that much because I
really do have that much faith I really
trust the as a director that's what
I call him that we're best friends yeah
we're gonna go have some coffee with him
afterwards thanks good thank you
yeah I trust him so much as a director
the final little shout-out that we
didn't say that I would say is that
another thing that I really appreciate
is that the love interest Lupita
nyong'o's character has a fully formed
character with an entire identity of
she's a person Y all with thoughts and
desires and a passion in life um and a
purpose everyone in this movie does and
which is fantastic oh no that's that's
just I mean I just gotta say I'm sorry
oh no everyone in this movie is great
and fantastic
and they avoid so many of the really
irritating girlfriend tropes she's she's
not irritating she's not a she's not a
wet blanket no not at all everybody's
given their due and fully fleshed out I
would recommend this 200% you should go
see this movie I think you will walk
away having had a great time at the
theater and with lots to chew on and
think about and what could you ask for
that's more than that out of your Marvel
movie really anything also the costuming
is ridiculous beautiful go see the movie
let us know what you think in the
comments below and again damn we'll be
back with the spoiler review after it
opens Danielle thank you so much oh
thank you so much for having me and we
will see you next time bye